[Music]
thank you
the top story is live from the Sky News
City Studio
Bank of England set to raise interest
rates for the 12th consecutive time as
it battles to curb inflation
the end of the line for first group as
it loses the transpennine express
contract
I'll be speaking to the chief executive
of Granger group the UK's largest listed
residential landlord
Plus plans to take British basketball
Global ahead of this weekend's playoff
finals
foreign
good morning this is Ian King live in
our business and economic news from the
Heart of the City well the bank of
England's monetary policy committee is
widely expected to raise interest rates
again today for the 12th consecutive
time the MPC is expected to raise bank
rate from four and a quarter percent to
four and a half percent at noon today
well that would take the bank's main
policy rate to its highest level since
October 2008 and would emulate similar
moves last week by the U.S federal
reserve and the European Central Bank
another hike in bank rate became nailed
on in the eyes of most Market
participants when the headline rate of
inflation came in at 10.1 percent for
March well above the 9.2 percent that
the bank itself was predicting in
February and confirming the UK as having
the highest rate of inflation in the G7
well joining me now is the head of
Economics at hsvc UK Commercial Banking
Liz Martins Liz welcome to you any doubt
in your mind that's what we're going to
get today
no not much doubt really like as you
said
um I think you know the bank of England
might have liked to pause and stop
raising interest rates but when that
inflation number came in considerably
higher than expectations and also the
wage number the day before had also been
extremely uh High relative to
expectations when those two pieces of
data came through
um it really nailed on the decision to
hike again
um and you know they have already moved
down from Raising by half a point to me
raising by a quarter as you said the FED
of the ECB did the same thing so it
seems highly likely they'll do that I
suppose the uncertainty is who's voting
for what will anyone vote for a larger
move or a smaller a smaller move that's
the bit that might be uh of more
interest today
well quite so I mean it's possible we
might even get a three-way split on the
NPC today
yeah definitely so we know that two
members of the MPC already think rates
have risen further than they need to
Sylvanas they've been voting for the
last few meetings uh to leave rates on
hold so they probably do that uh again
um then you might get some members of
the committee you say hold on that that
you know March inflation number really
worried me inflation is not going away
we need to act forcefully again and and
go back up to voting for a half a point
move base cases no we just got the
two-way split
um but totally possible
and what about the commentary I mean
obviously the fed and the European
Central Bank have hinted over the last
week that they may put further hikes on
pause for now I mean the bank of England
doesn't really have that luxury does it
no I think they'd like to have the
luxury but as you say the inflation
Outlook currently is is not conducive to
uh pausing and you know their
credibility is at risk as well you know
to to stop raising rates when inflation
is in double digits would be
um questionable I think so I think
they're going to keep the word thing
they had last time so essentially they
said look we're watching the indicators
watching the labor market we're watching
um you know core inflation
um and we will raise rates again if we
need to so the guidance is kind of
indicating a bias towards tightening or
raising rates it's not committing to
that
um but it is saying the bias is is in
that direction and I think they'll keep
that exact uh wording
um in the statement today
Liz one thing I get asked an awful lot
by viewers and readers let me try this
one on you for sizes uh why have the
bank's interest rate Rises to date
failed to reign in inflation
well I think you know rate Rises operate
with a lag don't they and that's the
really difficult part of this
um uh conundrum for the bank of England
you know the I think they underst
received wisdom is that it takes kind of
18 months to two years for a rate rise
to have its full effect so for those
members who don't want to raise rates
anymore they say it will you just need
to wait it's all coming down the
pipeline
um but of course it would have been nice
for the bank of England to see a bit
more evidence of things slowing down
things like the labor market unwinding
and actually this economy seems to be
re-accelerating not decelerating
um so you know even with that
understanding that the economy operates
with the lag I guess underlying momentum
in in the economy and in the labor
market was stronger than perhaps anybody
gave it credit for
now the market is currently pricing in a
peak uh the terminal rate if you like to
inform three-quarter to five percent I
mean would it be your assumption that
would get at least another quarter point
after today
yeah so another one on the 22nd of June
another quarter
um the bank of England will have two
inflation prints and two labor market
prints between its main meeting and its
June meeting so it's possible that
everything looks very different by the
22nd of June but the base case
um is that things will look a little
better but still worrying enough for
them to hike one more time so our view
is one more to 475 and then done but
risks I guess in in both directions as
well absolutely Liz busy day for you we
do appreciate you speaking to us today
thank you thank you
my first group which runs the
transpennine express rail service in
northern England and into Scotland is
not having its contract renewed the
department for transport has blamed
months of continuous cancellations on
its services what I'm joining you now is
our political correspondent Tamara Cohen
at Westminster I mean this is uh caused
a lot of unhappiness in northern England
the performance of this franchise
it has it will come as no surprise to
passengers who take it regularly that
there have been in the words of the
transport secretary this morning
continuous cancellations taking a toll
on passengers and on businesses in
January and February this year as many
as one in four services on the line were
canceled and thus comes this
announcement this morning threatened by
ministers over the last few months that
the line will be taken away from first
group which has operated it in various
guises since 2004 and basically brought
under government control run by an
operator of Last Resort now over the
last few years we've seen a few rail com
rail franchises brought under government
control when their contracts have ended
South Eastern for the last two years
Northern Rail and also lner so although
the governments say this is temporary
and they hope it will put back in
private hands at the evidence so far is
that rail franchises are being taken
in-house and then kept there now labor
say they've been calling for this for
wild why didn't they do it earlier the
labor mayor of West Yorkshire Tracy
braben has said that too often people
are crammed in like cattle and that it's
time for a change on that line now the
government say that this is not a silver
bullet not least because the ongoing
dispute with the train drivers Union as
left and their refusal to do overtime
has certainly not helped matters but at
a time when the government say they're
committed to leveling up and connecting
Northern cities they'll be hoping that
under this new Arrangement the
experience for passengers improves
thanks Tamara and I can tell you that
shares of first group are currently off
by some five percent on that news this
morning some other business news stories
for you now and the aircraft engine
maker Rolls-Royce said today it was on
course to hit its targets for the year
that's the aviation sector continues to
recover post pandemic or roles which is
paid for the number of hours and its
engines are airborne said that during
the first four months of the year flying
hours were at 83 percent of 2019 levels
and on track for the 80 to 90 range that
it's predicting for the full year rolls
also flagged new contract wins including
68 engines for Air India and another
contract to supply engines for the U.S
Navy's constellation class frigate
program
Vodafone said this morning that it is
entering a strategic relationship
agreement with its biggest single
shareholder Abu dhabi-based Emirates
telecommunications group the pair will
explore jointly offering cross-border
digital services and solutions including
fixed and mobile connectivity to
multinational customers and public
sector organizations they will also look
into adopting joint procurement well as
part of the arrangement the chief
executive of Emirates telecommunications
Group which currently owns 14.6 percent
of Vodafone will join the British
company's board
ITV said this morning that its
advertising sales during the first three
months of the year were down 10 on the
same period a year ago the free-to-air
broadcaster said this was as expected
and was better than the wider TV
advertising Market it meant as a whole
that ITV sales during the period fell by
seven percent to 776 million pounds but
then Carolyn McCall itv's chief
executive said the company's rebranded
streaming platform itvx was performing
strongly with digital revenues up 29 and
total streaming hours up 49 on the same
period a year ago the shares have
however Fallen by just over four percent
on that update
my late payments are costing European
businesses 275 billion euros a year
according to interim the Swedish credit
management company it carried out a
study of more than 10 000 companies
across 29 European countries and found
that on average businesses spend 29 of
their working year chasing overdue
payments well these payments take an
average of 74 days to resolve joining me
now is the president and chief executive
of interim Andres Rubio Andres fake good
to see you this morning um we talk about
late payments in this country a lot the
situation is actually even worse in uh
even big economies like France Germany
and Spain
well yeah I mean I'd say uh and good
morning and thank you for having me
unfortunately uh this report proves out
exactly what you're saying which is the
real economy is undergoing significant
challenges that manifest themselves in
late payments and although yes you see
the effect in Germany France and Spain
you're seeing in this report similar to
the consumer report we put out a few
months ago when I was last on the on the
program uh an effect in the larger
economies greater than the smaller
economies and frankly the UK is the most
affected uh but late payments it's
important to note Ian that late payments
are byproduct of the root causes of
what's ailing Enterprises Enterprises
are undergoing energy inflation the UK
is the most effective wage inflation
nine out of ten uh Enterprises are
experiencing extraordinary wage demand
so you have operating cost increasing
obviously you cover it very well there's
interest rate increases so financial and
operating costs are increasing
Enterprises are finding it very
difficult to recoup that in the pricing
of their products so profits are
declining the consensus is that this is
not going away also three out of four UK
firms and a slightly lower percentage
across all of Europe believe that this
will last for more than a year that's
putting Enterprises on their back foot
not on their front foot and putting them
more on a defensive posture as a
consequence they're scaling back growth
plans they're limiting indebtedness and
they're focusing on costs and
efficiencies and then that manifests
itself in dealing with late payments
when firms look at their working capital
in order to reduce their Investments and
improve their cash flow and that's a
significant drag with the 275 billion
figure and a 74-day figure that you
cited being the equivalent for example
just to put it in context for your
viewers of the GDP of Portugal or
Finland or the entire Revenue base of
Toyota or Google so it's a very
significant headwind for the economy and
it's also a cycle
for summer money indeed yes
approaches to dispute resolution over
late payments very much from country to
country across Europe
it does it does and unfortunately most
Enterprises particularly small and
medium-sized Enterprises are not
equipped to fully deal with it they
don't have the processes and the
financial controls they don't have the
Technologies they generally 50 to 60
percent of the firms Outsource it to a
lawyer uh 20 to 25 do it themselves 10
don't even deal with it but it's also a
very delicate situation because you're
dealing with your clients and obviously
you have a complete legal right to be
paid what you're owed but at the same
time this is a client with whom you want
to continue doing business for the most
part so lots of firms take a different
approach uh and I think what we need and
I'm not too not to promote my own
company but we need to actually look for
professional uh companies like ourselves
who deal with this on a daily basis we
do this across 24 countries we have 10
000 people dealing with this every
single day Outsourcing to those type of
firms would allow a communication and an
intermediary to resolve these things and
for them to continue their commercial
relationship
do you see any particular business
sectors that where late payments are
more of an issue than in others or is it
pretty widespread across the board
the there are differences although the
differences are not as wide as you would
think obviously the more Capital
intensive banking Finance industrial
companies those companies work there's
more Capital involved in the business
there's more payments moving around
those are worse uh the public sector
interestingly enough is also not great
at paying their uh their pay their
payments But ultimately at the other end
of the spectrum you have companies that
have a little bit more of a economic
tailwind and also less Capital intensity
Hospitality uh travel Leisure et cetera
doing relatively better but it's it's
affected across the board yeah
all right Andres we've got to leave it
there I'm afraid good to see you again
this morning thank you thank you very
much
France Remains the top destination in
Europe for foreign direct investment
with Britain in second place and Germany
in third well those are the findings of
the Europe attractiveness report
published this morning by the accounting
and business services giant ey which
reveals that the three countries account
for half of all inward investment
projects in Europe but it also reports
that foreign direct investment into
Europe stalled last year it was up just
one percent on 2021 and remained seven
percent lower than in 2019 before the
pandemic struck or joining me now is
Julie Lynn teagland she's e-wise area
managing partner for Europe the Middle
East India and Africa Julie good to see
you this morning
um why has investment stalled do you
think
you know I think we've been expecting a
huge bounce back on the back of covet
19. we didn't see that happen and let's
be honest the world around us has
changed quite a bit Ian we've got a war
in Ukraine going on we have an energy
crisis food prices are up inflation as
you've been reporting all morning is up
it's an extremely difficult environment
across Europe right now
looking at a country by country basis I
mean it seems to me that France is
pulling away from the UK and Germany why
is France doing relatively well
you know France has invested over the
past years and significant reforms
increasing the flexibility of their own
labor markets uh improving their tax
positioning across the space and that's
made them a much more business friendly
environment on a relative scale so
Francis done really well and you see the
impact of that coming through in FDI not
just this year but also in the previous
three
what I did think was quite interesting
though was that although France is
attracting more individual projects than
the UK more jobs are created per project
here in the UK than than elsewhere
absolutely and Ian I think one thing
that we should recognize the UK has
really been the leader when it comes to
creating r d jobs now those are really
high value uh Creation in terms of FDI
investment attracting some really
interesting Industries
um they've been leading the way on that
and that's important to remember
but we can't get away from brexit I mean
you're quite clear in your report that
uh brexit is actually hurting the UK's
position
I do think that Braxton has had an
impact I don't think it's been
incredibly positive it just in light of
the volatility and the changes we see
across the world and I mentioned a few
of those a couple of seconds ago brexit
just adds to the complexity when we're
looking for an environment of free trade
do you think that's a temporary
phenomenon do you think that the UK
eventually as it starts to sort of pull
different levers from the EU can recover
that situation
you know I think it's the U is the UK
really focuses on bettering their trade
relationships and some of the accession
to the trans-pacific trade agreement are
the indication of that I do think
there's an opportunity for the UK to
smooth the waves and create better trade
patterns reducing those barriers and the
bureaucracy that comes in between
now one of the other little nuggets that
jumps out at me was is which countries
are doing particularly well in terms of
attracting investment on the the yellow
leader Jersey here goes to Romania
massive increase in investment projects
absolutely and Ian I I think it's been a
real phenomena you look at southern
Europe I'm going to say Italy turkey
Romania and you really see that Supply
chains across Europe are on the move
they are completely being redesigned
taking advantage of wage Arbitrage but
equally taking advantage of really
skilled labor across an umbrella of
European consistency of law that's
attractive massive amounts of investment
now that's a good thing in my view on
the back of covid we expected a lot of
Supply chains to change a lot more near
Shoring and Concepts like friends
Shoring have been invented we see those
impacts across Europe I don't think
that's the end of this journey I think
you're going to see more of that and and
that's why I think you you talk about
what we just mentioned UK being high on
the scale of strong r d southern Europe
being high on the scale in terms of
supply chain moving take advantage of
that wage Arbitrage and skilled labor
all right Julie we have to leave it
there so fascinating report thanks for
discussing it with me today
thank you very much Ian
foreign
on Wall Street last night following
another decline in U.S inflation was
followed by a dole session overnight in
the asia-pacific region most of the
markets were largely flattered amid
concerns over deflationary pressures in
China and a mixed bag of corporate
updates from Japanese companies well in
Europe stocks have rallied after a
two-day losing streak here's the current
picture all of the main Continental
European indices are in positive
territory right now again it's a busy
results today talking points include ing
the biggest bank in the Netherlands it
said by some four percent in Amsterdam
after its quarterly results came in
better than expected but the German
drugs and biotech giant buyer it Shares
are off nearly seven percent in
Frankfurt and that followed a downbeat
trading update here in London well the
ftse 100 is also in positive so it's
more or less flat to be honest looking
at that consumer and Healthcare stocks
leading the way among the leading Blue
Chip gainers right now is Hayley on
that's the owner of Sensodyne toothpaste
the shares there nearly two percent to
the good on positive broker moment
another Blue Chip going higher this
morning is the aerospace engineer
Melrose that shares up another one and a
quarter percent following yesterday's
well-received trading update on the
downside Airtel Africa Who's chief
executive you might recall we had on the
program recently well it shares a down
three and a half percent it's got
results out this morning as ever at this
time of year a number of stocks have
gone ex-dividend in other words they're
trading for the first time without
rights to the latest payout those going
x-div today include HSBC BP and Tesco
all of those are adjusting lower to
reflect the fact they've gone XD today
outside the ftse well first group look
at that uh mentioned them a little early
in the program or five and a quarter
percent after it lost the rights to
operate the transpennine express row
contract well Asos off another four and
a half percent after yesterday's Rising
losses it fell by 20 yesterday on the
foreign exchange markets well pretty
much uh unchanged for the pound that's
often third and one percent against the
US dollar ahead of this lunchtime's rate
decision decision it's up by nearly a
sixth of one percent though against the
Euro The single currency off half of one
percent almost against the Greenback as
for the oil price well that has clawed
back some of yesterday's losses or news
of a sharper than expected drop in U.S
gasoline inventory is about a Brink
crude will currently set you back
77.9 cents a bow that is up nine tenths
of one percent joining me now is the
head of investment at interactive
investor Victoria scholar Victoria good
to see you this morning um let's start
with uh some news that we got overnight
in the US we had uh quarterly results
from Disney
yep that's right and we saw that it
largely met expectations on the top and
bottom line but it's Disney plus
subscriber figure fell by 4 million
missing expectations which is why the
stock was off by almost five percent
after hours I think investors largely
Shrugged off a stronger performance in
its theme parks where we saw a jump in
Revenue uh for that division to 7.7
billion dollars
um but you know last year was very tough
for Disney caught up in the so-called
Tech wreck when um the whole of the US
tech sector came under heavy selling
pressure but we have seen Disney uh
enjoy a significant recovery you know
it's been doing a restructuring
including slashing seven thousand jobs
there's the return of Bob Iger as well
as CEO after uh retiring less than a
year ago and of course there's been that
broader Rebound in technology as well
a lot of company news on this side of
the Atlantic uh to Grapple with this
morning Victoria one that caught your
eye was Wood Group
yes that's right uh you know Wood Group
has been in Focus lately because of this
potential takeover from Apollo the U.S
private Equity giant but it reported
first quarter revenues of 1.45 uh
billion dollars in the first quarter
Rising year on year but it's order book
actually slowed and it's kept its full
year outlook unchanged and highlighted
the uncertain macro economic Outlook but
like I say the real Focus for this
company is as investors await this key
deadline before which Apollo must decide
whether or not it wants to make a formal
offer for Wood Group Apollo has also set
at sites on thg and we've seen a number
of private Equity firms uh setting their
eyes on UK companies lately because of
that discount in terms of valuations
with the ftse underperforming the dats
or the cat over the last five years and
also because of the weakness in Sterling
which again makes UK targets more
attractive but you know we've seen in
Sterling start to come back it's back up
at a one-year high so perhaps the time
is ticking and we might see more of
these PE offers come to the table uh
quite soon interesting we're all about
Rolls-Royce I mean a fairly reassuring
trading update this morning but it
didn't really move the dial so fast the
share price was concerned I mean is that
because it's had a good run already this
stock
yeah it's one of the best performing
stocks on the ftse 100 lately
um it reaffirmed its guidance for the
full year but I think there's some
disappointment that it didn't actually
upgrade that guidance uh given that
there's been so much enthusiasm towards
this stock lately with uh the new CEO
and the rebounding international travel
post pandemic you know this stock is up
about 50 so far this year that some of
those gains uh today is in the midst of
a major transformation program and
although we have seen this major rally
so far this year the stock is still
trading at less than half of its uh
market cap back in 2018 before the
pandemic so there could be more upside
or at least there's a long way to go to
try to reclaim those highs that is
fascinating I hadn't realized that
Victoria good to see you this morning
thank you
you always learn something on this
program I hope still to come here on Ian
King live I'm going to be speaking to
the chief executive of Granger the UK's
largest listed residential landlord it's
just published its half year results
don't go away
[Music]
thank you
the band has rallied moderation interest
rates peaking up at six percent the
highest for 14 years will that be the
peak will it be a little bit lower
prices it's closer to a potential crash
so many words so many meanings but what
do they mean for you and your finances
stay up to date on Sky News
I'm Adam Parsons and Sky's Europe
correspondent based here in Brussels
problems have been pulled up out and
they're being used as missiles for hell
at these police
made by people who dare to challenge
[Music]
nice to see you again Mr Barney
why meeting you
he does have the potential to stymie an
enormous economic deal we take you to
the heart of stories that shape our
world
what strikes you when you come to this
Glacier is not just the way in which the
environment is changing but the speed at
which those changes are happening
foreign
welcome back now the number of homes
available to rent in the UK has fallen
by a third over the past 18 months
according to data recently published by
the property website zoopla one company
in the Forefront of attempts to remedy
that is Granger which is the UK's
largest listed residential landlord this
morning the company which owns and
manages more than 9 000 rental homes
across the UK and that's the two percent
rise in adjusted earnings to 47.1
million pounds for the six months to the
end of March headline pre-tax profits
however fell by 94 to 5.7 million pounds
due to valuation movements well joining
me now I'm very pleased to say it's
Helen Gordon she's the chief executive
of Grainger hell and welcome to you um a
very quick word I don't want to get too
bogged down in the numbers but what
informed these uh valuation movements
well we have seen an outward yield
movement and that's really come from a
view on Rising interest rates
um having said that we offset
um that by strong rental growth
um and that's new lettings and also
um and also relative growth which we at
Grainger normally align to
um wage inflation so we've seen 6.8
rental growth 12 rental growth overall
and uh that's very much aligned with
wage inflation at the moment so a good
rental story but obviously interest
rates affecting valuations
yeah you kind of preempted my next
question I was going to ask you what the
approach was to uh rent increases I mean
does it very much from location to
location as well or is it a flat uh
increased links to wage inflation as you
say
will grind your own and manage all our
own properties and we have a really
strong customer relationship so we
understand customers
um affordability
um our main customer demographic is in
that 25 to 34 age group they're spending
about 29 of their income on rent and so
we're very much aligning it to
um their wage inflation so we've seen
um good and good wage inflation coming
through and we've been aligning our
rents to um towards that so it's still
very affordable for our customers we
concentrate on that mid-market approach
to renting what's the duration of a
typical tenancy few these days
so we concentrate on customer retention
and
um our average tenant stays with us for
just under three years and when you
think it's in that 25 to 34 age group
that's actually quite a good statistic
now I think you're targeting something
like
1640 new homes this year what sort of
progress have you made to date
yeah we've got seven new large openings
later this year and that's going to
really boost our income in 2024 but
we've actually got a pipeline of 6 000
new homes so it's uh you know very very
strong pipeline when you compare it to
our existing portfolio and that pipeline
is uh fully funded
um that we've got over well around three
and a half thousand homes on site at the
moment so that's uh you know a really
strong pipeline to come what are you
seeing right now in terms of build costs
station from new schemes that are coming
through that is actually now softening
right interesting and what about
planning permission I mean this is
obviously a constant bug bear for uh the
industry it's that kind of affects the
timing of you delivering on the pipeline
that you're aiming for
we've been very successful at planning
consents I think you know London which
is seen as being the hardest City we've
achieved nearly 2 000 planning consensus
uh 2000 homes in the last couple of
years but planning consents throughout
the whole of the UK at their lowest
um level ever on record so you're right
to point out that planning is a
challenge but we tend to be developing
in urban locations which are probably
less sensitive than some of the sort of
Greenfield and Suburban locations now
Bill to rent has become quite a hot area
in recent years the likes of m g and
legal in general are moving into this
patch has that made life more difficult
for you in terms of land acquisition
there are a position strategy is strong
um a question I often get asked is you
know sort of are people leaving the
sector and of course it's proved
incredibly resilient
um and so there is a lot of appetite not
just from institutional
um players but also Sovereign wealth
funds to own in the long term rented
homes in the UK and I think that's a
really good thing for the UK economy
because having a good well-financed
private rented sector will see the end
of poor bad landlords and I think that's
that's good for the UK economy it's good
for Mobility it's good for leveling up
it's good for so many things so I
actually
um welcome the fact that we've got lots
of people uh seeing this as a really
good place to invest
obviously rents are rising appreciably
across the economy as a whole people
like Sadiq Khan the London mayor are
talking about rent controls what would
that mean for your business
well I think that
um the this government and I think also
across all political part parties they
know that the real problem on renting is
the supply and you started this uh piece
by talking about the um the fallen in
supply of rented rented homes so one of
one of the things I would say is um
we've seen in Scotland that where
they've introduced red caps
um it has actually led to a fall-off in
Supply arising in rent and a fall off of
investment so for me
um I think that um we we across all of
the Mayors they don't have the ability
to bring it in and I think it would be
very wise for this government and any
subsequent government to think about
what that will do to the supply side as
well
um I think also it behaves us to be very
responsible as landlords in terms of how
we grow our rents as well
well you couldn't have been more clear
on that Helen we haven't had you on the
program for a while it's good to see you
again thanks for joining me nice to see
you
still to come here on in King life
Digital Services provide an event is the
latest company looking to switch from
London to the US I'll be asking its
chief executive why it's shifting its
focus
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
news to bring you which is that two
Metropolitan Police Service officers
have been dismissed without notice for
punching and kicking a 14 year old boy
during his arrest before lying about the
incident in their statements immediately
afterwards a hearing of the independent
office for police conduct heard that
police constables Alexa zileski and
Connor Ryan were accused of using
excessive force on the child in North
London in April 2021 more on that story
throughout the morning here on Sky News
as we get it
now we've talked a lot on this program
recently about the falling popularity of
the London Stock Market crh the owner of
tarmac is Shifting its main listing from
London to New York and flutter
entertainment the owner of Paddy Power
and Betfair is thinking of doing
likewise I mean while the chip designer
arm Holdings recently decided against a
secondary listing in London despite the
government's pleas well another company
that's upping sticks is noventic it's a
global provider of digital
transformation and cyber Security
Solutions and services it's been listed
in London for 18 months but it's now
looking to relocate to NASDAQ who are
joining me now to talk about this is
noventix chief executive irvae Tesla
ervay tell me why you're going
good morning Jan and uh I mean first
thank you for having an event today
um yeah I mean it's not uh yeah it's not
a matter of you know London versus
NASDAQ or or London versus New York uh
in the case of dementia we had a
successful IPO in London change in 2021
since then we've been doing a lot of
things to improve the business to keep
growing to deliver value and we've been
also looking at options uh to make sure
that we keep delivering that value to
all of our stakeholders and we've got to
a point when working with Corner Rose
was the most obvious way to move forward
keep accelerating our voice and bringing
value to our customers you know the the
markets where we uh where we open it so
that's how we decided to uh to make that
move
your share price is off something like
75 since the IPO why do you think London
investors haven't bought into the story
I think there's you know a number of
things I mean one we've been through a
year of major activities we demered from
our Russian entity we sold our Russian
business uh we apprehended the company
but basically what we want to achieve is
get the right valuation of the company
that we believe is undervalued today and
we want to gain access to Tech saggy
investor that we believe are are very
um very present at the NASDAQ it was
really a Tech Exchange to gain access to
Capital to again keep investing for the
growth of our business we're we're
growing Young on kind of balance with a
balanced model of organic Investments
and inorganic Investments uh in the last
12 months we're probably at seven new
companies across you know the countries
where we operate in the emerging markets
and we want to just keep doing that
you just use the phrase tech savvy
investors and you put your finger on
there what a lot of people think is a
critical issue here which is that
investors in the UK don't really get
Tech
well I mean I'm not gonna I'm not gonna
make that comment I'm not gonna build on
what you just said
um but what I think is it's a matter of
scale and it's a matter of as you know
the NASDAQ is your pure technology play
right so by Design By definition the
players are texting and I'm not saying
there's no tax selling investors in the
UK by the way our IPO was very
successful proving that you know a
number of investors here were Keen to go
and support the growth of a business
academic
now your market cap I think and fairly
recently has been around 270 million
dollars by how much would you hope it
might rise when you switch to NASDAQ
well the the model and what we
communicated last week when we announced
the business combination with uh Coral
gross is a valuation around 800 million
dollars at NASDAQ
now you've mentioned you've just issued
a trading update I mean you are still
seeing in growth uh generally across the
piece are there any business segments
where it's a little softer demand
no I I think I mean obviously you know
the the world is is pretty buggy uh I
think what is very
specific at noventique given our history
of operating in the I was Emerging
Markets we have a very specific
operating model which is very
decentralized so we have a lot of
extremely talented people on the ground
that are connected to the different
markets and so we are aware to adapt to
the major Market shifts but also to the
major Market opportunities and we
strongly believe that in these markets
despite the global geopolitical
endurance and economic environment
technology
Services digital transformation cyber
security everything that's coming with
AI supported pushed by the likes of
Microsoft because we're also a very
strategic partner Global partner or
Microsoft also Google Amazon web
services cities VMware I remember all of
them are counting on a company like
innoventi to have that local governments
that local market connection so that we
can help these customers in these
emerging economies to go through their
digital transformation genre okay we
have to leave it there I'm afraid good
to talk to you this morning thank you
thank you very much thank you yeah thank
you bye
now we're going to stay with this team
because SoftBank the Japanese Tech
investor that owns the chip designer arm
Holdings has reported a net loss
overnight of 7.18 billion US dollars for
the year to the end of March while it's
written down the value of its Flagship
Vision fund portfolio for the fifth
consecutive quarter to reflect a decline
in Tech valuations Will the fund's
recent performance helps explain why
SoftBank is floating on but its decision
to opt for a New York listing and not
London has prompted a good deal of
soul-searching about the UK Market's
attractiveness as a destination for
international businesses but some would
argue the damage was done back in 2016
when Theresa May's government desperate
to show the UK was still open for
business after the brexit vote nodded
through the Takeover by SoftBank in the
first place well those events and the
birth of the company have been
chronicled in a new book The everything
blueprint published today and joining me
now is the author James Ashton he's also
chief executive of the quoted companies
Alliance James good to see you this
morning let's get to the heart of it
should this takeover have been allowed
in the first place I mean you know we we
make so much Ian of the UK being an open
market and that there really weren't the
controls in in 2016 to uh to stop it I
think and actually in the days when it
happened I mean that famous tweet from
Philip Hammond this is a wonderful deal
for Britain he'd been off his six days
um you know to Theresa May I don't think
it unpacked yet so it was um we were in
no position to to say no at that stage
and what's what's interesting in writing
about that then and writing about the
events of the last couple of months is
that the sale of arm then was seen as a
validation of the UK and hadam come back
now that was also validation of the UK
so it's interesting how this big
company's become such a such a a symbol
if you like such a crown jewel it really
has I mean the UK is now taking a more
interventionist approach towards
takeovers on things issues like National
Security do you think the Takeover will
be waved through today under today's
circumstances
it's difficult because I think there is
um I don't think we know where we stand
yet with semiconductors we are waiting
for a you know we're waiting for a long
time for a semiconductor strategy as to
what as to what the UK thinks there are
things you can do
um you know around National interest of
course
um had it been a US company then and now
it certainly wouldn't have happened
um today I think um well interesting as
you say see from your last uh your guest
sadly the companies are leaving in any
case I mean you make the point in the
book though that uh had to be a
shareholders ultimately did agree to it
and they were happy to sell I mean there
was obviously a big uh shareholder who
was very unhappy at it but people waved
it through the investors took their
money they did I mean they waved it
through in an astonishing fashion I mean
it was I think I put in the book 64 days
from the first approach the lunch uh you
know on the Waterside in in Turkey to
the deal completing and really really
senior City people had never seen
anything like it that the speed with
which it went through how do you think
uh arm has fared under softbanks
ownership I think the thing is and we
see the figures we see the figures and
the this morning and clearly this is the
time in the cycle when they need to
they're fattening up the market again so
they have to look good I think the thing
is arm is such a long long term business
if you plan IP today you're starting to
get revenues probably five years from
now
um from from the end customers I think
we can say today is that the ownership
under SoftBank has not been a failure
um I think we need to look a little
longer to see whether it's been a great
success certainly the revenues are are
good roughly the business is twice as
big as it was when it was taken over in
the year they've just posted there's
about six percent Top Line growth which
is pretty good particularly when you
think this is a company that's been
wedded to smartphones for many years and
smartphones have had a terrible year
there's some smartphone decline
um so so that's pretty good I mean
profitability you can't really tell yet
there's an awful lot they put aside for
for staff compensation and so on but I'm
sure we'll see more as we get towards
September as a standalone business once
again will there be things that it is
able to do that it couldn't do as part
of SoftBank
um I'm not sure I mean I think there was
all this talk when it was was taken over
that it would work across the whole
portfolio of
um at softbanks Investments and really
it was quite a discreet business
um within that had it gone to Nvidia
that was that was a real uh that would
have been a real integration piece if
you like but I think no I think it could
work
um it could work either way what it's
had the benefit of uh over the last
seven years you know we talk about
SoftBank has invested in arm well
actually softbanks money went to Arms
shareholders seven years ago the best
thing that SoftBank has done for um um
is not take a dividend which clearly if
you come to Market this is always an
issue with the investors whether New
York or London what is the dividend when
do you pay the dividend what's the yield
and so on now arm was born of course in
Cambridge it has several thousand
employees there to this day does it
still retain that sort of cambridge-ness
to its culture I think the um I think
the great strength of arm was that and
the successive arm was it thought
internationally from day one it had no
money no patents it didn't have the
customers the first thing the management
did was get on the plane to Asia again
and again
um the if you like the the locals of the
company has drifted to the west coast of
the states over the years there's more
management there now than in the UK
there's 2 800 people in Cambridge
um you know I think it you know if you
were only a UK company you wouldn't have
had the success you've had but I think
um you know we can we can be grateful
and we can build on 2800 you know
highly skilled highly paid jobs in in
Cambridge absolutely James good to see
you this morning thank you
a bit of breaking news to uh bring you a
BBC conflict of interest review has
found that there were no concerns about
Richard Sharp's Integrity while he was
BBC chairman it was commissioned after
Mr Sharp was embroiled in a cronyism
route involving Boris Johnson which
ultimately led to his resignation at BBC
chairman two weeks ago more on that as
we get it
still to come here on in King life the
chief executive of the British
basketball league on plans to go Global
stay with us
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
moderation interest rates peaking up and
up at six percent the highest for 14
years will that be the peak will it be a
little bit lower prices it's closer to a
potential crash so many words so many
meanings but what do they mean for you
and your finances stay up to date on Sky
News
I'm Adam Parsons I'm Skies Europe
correspondent based here in Brussels
[Music]
have been used
made by people who dare to challenge
[Music]
see you again Mr Bunny
why meeting you
fishing does have the potential to
stymie an enormous economic deal
we take you to the heart of stories that
shape our world
what strikes you when you come to this
Glacier is not just the way in which the
environment is changing but the speed at
which those changes are happening
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
Global insight made local
invest in your future Sky News Financial
reports sponsored by interactive
investor
[Music]
thank you
invest in your future Sky News Financial
reports sponsored by interactive
investor
welcome back now this Sunday more than
16 and a half thousand fans will fill
the O2 in London to watch the playoff
finals in the men and women's British
basketball league as the London Lions
take on the Leicester Riders basketball
in the UK's relatively small beer
compared with the super rich MBA across
the Atlantic but the British basketball
league has just brought in a new chief
executive at the end of the last year to
try and change all that Aaron Raiden
previously worked at the MBA meta and
Disney now he has ambitious plans to
turn British basketball into a global
player and Aaron joins me now welcome to
you I mean the UK has some very strong
team support Traditions football rugby
Cricket can basketball ever really hope
to compete with them
so I think I look at this as not just a
sports competitive but really an
entertainment competitive uh landscape
and and even just offline we were
talking about Disney before and so when
we think about about basketball we're
thinking about presenting an
entertainment product that is going to
drive attention and so in that respect
we're competing of course with football
and rugby and other sports but we're
also competing with Netflix and Tick
Tock and Facebook and where other people
spend their attention and so our goal is
really to produce you know a very
entertaining and compelling product that
brings joy to its fans and and creates
value for our marketing Partners as a
result of doing so I think from a from a
target audience standpoint the thing
that's particularly encouraging about
where we are today
is that the core of our audience is a 13
to 34 year old which is really in the
media landscape the hardest audience to
reach so I think that that we have a
very strong foundational basis to build
a compelling uh business upon where we
can drive value for partners it's the
aim to drive participation as well as
audiences I think it's a little bit of
both so so you know I think it starts
with the experience of of going to a
game in person we want to have an
amazing night out for individuals for
families that those people become
effectively our brand ambassadors
because of what a great time they've had
at the event at the same time we're
really focused on producing content
product that's everything from the
broadcast to all sorts of digital
content and distribution across multiple
platforms I think a key piece of that is
you know particularly in the sports
landscape it's very easy to produce
highlights there's automated tools to do
that you know you sort of any type of
platform form you see all sorts of
different highlights what we wanted we
want of course you need to do that
that's sort of table stakes in addition
to that we want to do storytelling we
want excuse me we want people to
understand uh and begin to create an
emotive connection with our players our
teams uh even League Executives
um because that's really what drives
engagement and if you look at sort of uh
the sports landscape particularly over
the last couple of years
those that have done that well have
really seen elevation of their
performance so F1 would drive to survive
uh welcome to wrexham is another example
where you've seen the level of
Engagement increased dramatically as a
result of creating a connection with the
personalities that are involved in those
in those Sports what about Grassroots
yeah to invest in more courts so so each
of our each of our clubs run run
Grassroots programs uh it's an
incredibly important uh driver in fact
my own personal history I coached and
ran a Grassroots organization in
Brooklyn New York for for many many
years
um and so enabling kids to have the
ability not only to have facility to
play I've noticed it rains a lot here in
in this country so having indoor
facilities is is really important and
helping to provide the funding for that
but also the coaching and the skill
development I think you know typically
in sort of in a football system you have
these academies and they and they they
do skill development and basketball it's
it's a little bit different you can have
that uh but also a lot of the best
talent particularly the GB Talent we'll
go over to the United States to go and
play in college basketball and then
you know what we're hoping and what
we're starting to see is that a lot of
those people are are coming back to play
here I think a a huge part of our
eventual success will be in tracing the
Arc of Team GB both on the men's and
women's side and hopefully elevating
that performance to a world-class level
well you've got your work cut out though
I mean the NBA is a massive draw I mean
a young basketball player from this
country can own a life-changing sum of
money going there which they probably
can't hear uh yes we're not competing so
I think from a talent competitive
perspective like that is the Pinnacle of
of the sport and it's uh both from a
competitive standpoint but also from a
compensation standpoint we're not going
to be uh anytime soon uh competing with
that with that type of attractiveness
from a competitive standpoint
the same time there are 450 people who
play in the NBA there's probably
2500 people probably good enough to play
in the NBA it's just a function of
circumstance and so uh you know from our
standpoint we're looking to build sort
of the next best option in terms of
um
uh where where those players can
actually hone their craft and
demonstrate it thanks thank you that's
it from me I'm back at 10 o'clock
tomorrow morning do stay tuned though up
next it's Anna Jones with all the build
up to the bank of England rates decision
at midday see you tomorrow cheerio
[Music]